another part of what I work on is
questions of pluralism and in the United
States so you know i mean frankly like
in the last 10 years but for a long time
Americans have been obsessed with you
know what says religious pluralism in
the u.s. how is it becomes very recently
it's become this thing that our
religiously plural state is something
that we connect very strongly in
political discourse to democracy right
so to them to you know religious freedom
religious pluralism they all get
connected and wrapped into particular
kinds of political discourses and in
fact policy international policy issues
as well but at the same time the sort of
living experience of pluralism like you
know like what actually it's certain
kinds of what kinds of religions are
seen as being properly plural right are
sort of properly playing the game of
pluralism within the United States puts
a lot of restrictions on I mean it's not
sort of some open field of everybody
getting to do what they want there are a
lot of restrictions and regulations
about what happens religiously in the US
right so that's the other part of my
work right which is really about these
questions of how American secular is it
really values a certain form of
pluralism that it ceases natural and
that it exports and that it forms a lot
of what we do who we think we are as a
people so I do think there are really
interesting connections between these
two parts of the work that I do I mean
most of what I'm pushing at this
uses thinking about the ways that our
understandings of religion are supported
by non religious institutions as much as
they are by religious institutions right
so that there's not just the church's
telling this is so this really sort of
radically not radically but does
somewhat shift the grounds on which we
think about church-state relations right
what is what is that relation really
depends a lot on what you think church
is what you think so so yeah I mean we
have to talk about religion is about
religion is about power so religion is
about politic can be